nos david président de l'association de
chasse maritime de l'étang de berre dans
les bouches du rhône
bonjour merci de répondre à nos
questions sur arte france ce matin une
centaine de cars est annoncé en fin de
matinée à amiens les chasseurs non
content de défendre leur passion face à
une ministre de tutelle l'amiénoise
barbara broccoli qui selon eux ne les
défend pas vous vous sentez abandonnés
par l'état en tant que chasseur
écoutez on est plus qu abandonner la
chasse est une tradition française
inscrit dans la constitution
les français se sont battus il ya très
longtemps pour ce droit aujourd'hui on
est menacé et erronée plus qu'eux et on
les avait insultés puisque les gens on
essaie de discuter avec les gens de
notre obliger nos campagnes et on
n'arrive pas et on se fait insulter on
se fait casser des poses que vous votez
ici il ya tout il ya tout à redire là
dessus les malheureusement l'on vit dans
un système où on monte les uns contre
les autres plutôt connaître essayer de
partager des idées et surtout les
passions le chasseur n'est pas une
personne qui va détruire ça se saurait
la destruction des animaux ou des
oiseaux ont malheureusement on n'a pas
refait pas aux chasseurs le chasseur est
là pour veiller à ce que tout se passe
bien c'est lui qui fait des comptages
sait aujourd'hui qui mieux que le
chasseur pour faire des cottages et
veiller à l'équilibré d'assurer deux
groupes de nos campagnes ratées sont
jugées cruelles par les défenseurs de
l'environnement n'en a entendu un seul
reportages des médias ce qui est des
revenus chanter c'est sous leur
répondais je l'aurais pas fait de
malheureusement dû nous dire un truc
malheureusement on les invite à
participer à des réunions de travail
avec nous sur un bon nombre de projets
ces gens là ne viennent jamais mais
quand je dis j'avais sait jamais et ils
sont toujours aux abonnés absents donc
c'est bien beau de critiquer mais qu'est
ce qu'ils apportent quelle est la valeur
ajoutée et sur quoi tout ça est il fondé
sur rien donc est ce qu'ils connaissent
les animaux à ce qu'ils ont déjà une est
ce qu'il est est ce qu'ils aiment et ce
qu'ils en ont un élevage et ce qu'ils en
ont à leur maison à leur domicile je
pense pas donc ces gens là en fait ce
sont des gens qui prennent des décisions
d'un fauteuil sarkolâtres pour autant
bien sûr je suis triste et pourtant le
conseil veut interdire à veut rendre
illégales certaines formes de chasse
traditionnelle jugé contraire à la
directive européenne
celle ci a interdit notamment la chasse
d'oiseaux son extinction d'espèces et
pas d'autre moyen de chasser sans mettre
en danger des espèces potentiellement
protéger des nous les espèces au nez on
les choisit on n'attrape pas à n'importe
quoi comme un oiseau on fait très
attention à ce que l'on fait on a chez
josé qu'on a frappé qui sont protégés
ont fait des comptages et les oiseaux
qui sont protégés
aujourd'hui
oui pour y avoir d'autres moyens mais
non ça fait partie de la tradition
française ça fait des années que ces
traditions sont ancrées de chez les
chasseurs qu'ils soient nous pour les
bouches-du-rhône donc on a frappe le nom
d'oiseau est là qu on nous interdit la
glu et pourtant on fait très très
attention dans d'autres deux entretiens
victoire ils ont d'autres moyens de
capture mais il n'y a pas de soucis de
nos voiliers de capture on n'arrive pas
à comprendre infestation la main qui a
aujourd'hui avec tous et anti chasse
contre nous c'est nous on est dans les
évite à travailler avec nous et eux ils
plutôt que de travailler avec nous et
d'essayer de nous comprendre ils font de
la résistance en chine et puisqu'il
participe à aucun débat aucune réunion c
c'est un dialogue de sourds et de
malentendants c'est un gros gros
problème est ce qu'il faut reconnaître
aussi c'est que
nous on est on est chasseur aujourd'hui
dans la rivalité on reçoit les gens des
grandes villes on n'a rien contre les
gens des grandes villes bien au
contraire on est là pour les accueillir
et leur expliquer notre méthode notre
méthode de vie mais eux qui arrivent des
grandes villes se porte plus que nous
allions décor qui supporte plus que nous
ayons une petite ville il supporte plus
de nous voir ils veulent acheter mg
toutes les campagnes ils veulent courir
les colis de communes vals à respecter
la nature dans notre nature nous avons
des périodes de nidification ne sont pas
respectés et si elles ne sont pas
respectées non pas par des chasseurs
et par les gens qui ne chasse pas qu'ils
ne connaissaient pas la nature et c'est
très très très très tristes et nous on
travaille d'arrache-pied avec
l'intégration la fédération nationale
pour pouvoir éduquer ces gens faire des
programmes d'éducation de de ces gens
aujourd'hui vous arrive dans deux
défiance entre la ville et la campagne
absolument absolument aujourd'hui en
nous je vous répète les gens de la ville
sont les bienvenus à la campagne
aujourd'hui bon les gens c'est comme ça
c'est la démographie française les gens
partent beaucoup à la retraite j'ai
beaucoup de retraités va de leur
appartement à paris vend de leur
appartement à lyon aix et ira etc et
atterrissent dans les campagnes
seulement si j'aime pas région de
campagne on n'y est pour rien et nous
nous on est on est pas contre ces gens
au contraire au contraire on les
accueille on veut travailler avec lui un
but réducteur
pardon c'est pas un peu réducteur de
dire que les gens de la ville n'aime pas
les gens de la campagne et
malheureusement le subit tous les jours
il ya beaucoup de il ya beaucoup de gens
se faire insulter aujourd'hui à semer
casser les postes ne sont pas des gens
de vos tiroirs
et c'est triste quand même parce que
nous on est on est on est pas comme ça
elle veut les accueillir on veut
travailler avec eux on veut partager nos
passions partagées notre histoire
partagée notre méthode denis si dans sa
méthode de vie merci bruno david d'avoir
répondu à une question je rappelle que
vous êtes le président de l'association
de chasse maritime de l'étang de berre
dans le département des bouches du rhône